hey everyone its here with registered
nurse Orion calm and in this video I
want to go over how to study for
pharmacology pharmacology is one of
those classes that US health science
majors cannot bypass and it's known for
having a tough reputation because you
have to know a lot of material in a
short amount of time there's a lot of
drugs covered a lot of side-effect so it
can be overwhelming in this video I'm
going to go over the common mistakes
that pharmacology students make when
approaching the class and give you some
tips and tricks on how to study an
eighth pharmacology so let's get started
first let's talk about those common
mistakes first a lot of students have
issues with developing a study method
they get really overwhelmed because in
most pharmacology classes you'll cover
material in your lecture class for about
three weeks and then you'll have an exam
and on that exam you will be covering up
to five to eight chapters and that is a
lot of material so it's very
overwhelming and you wonder how do I
even begin to study next a lot of people
have issues learning what material to
study they question should I read every
chapter word by word and some of these
chapters are like a hundred to two
hundred pages and you'll spend a lot of
time reading or do you just memorize the
powerpoints that your teachers give out
so a lot of conflicting things and you
want to know how to actually target and
tackle this material next people try to
memorize individual drug names instead
of the group based on its prefix or
suffix and doing this learning how to
memorize based on prefix and suffixes
and classes can save you a lot of time
and help you understand this material
next last but not least sometimes
depending on how you're juggling
everything some students tend to cram in
pharmacology is just one of those
classes it's
really hard to cram for because like I
said there's a lot of material you have
to know so if your test is in two days
and two days before the exam is the
first time you've looked at the material
it can be really hard to actually
understand and digest that material so
here in a second I want to go over these
tips and tricks to help you ace
pharmacology that you can make your own
and help you either increase your grade
or get through the class okay now let's
go over those studies strategies number
one very important you want to learn
drug prefixes and suffixes of the
generic name not the brand name but the
generic name rather than trying to
memorize individual drug names because
each group of drugs usually will have
very similar endings or the beginnings
the prefix which is the beginning and
the suffix which is the ending and let
me show you an example okay there's
cardiac meds known as beta blockers you
have beta blockers calcium channel
blockers ACE inhibitors and they all
usually have the same each category has
the same suffixes for instance let's
look at the beta blockers there's a lot
of beta blockers so I just pick three
but you have Motoko all attila and
propanolol notice at the end the suffix
is oh LOL and these share the common
side-effects which are slow heart rate
cold and hands or feet or tiredness so
say you have a test question on
pharmacology that says you have a
patient that comes into the clinic and
they report feeling tired they have cold
hands and feet and whenever they check
their pulse their pulse is about 49 50
and you look at the patient's
medications and this is what the
patient's taking and it gives you a
whole list of medications and your
choices will be a B C or D which
medication do you suspect that the
patient is taking that is causing these
symptoms and you would know based on
memorizing the oh lol suffix of beta
blockers that this group of drugs can
cause these side-effects so what this
does is it just
really helps you take a whole bunch of
group of drug names and memorize the
suffix or prefix to apply to side
effects and how they work on the body
the pharma Kinesis so very helpful tool
next make flashcards this is one of the
best ways to study for pharmacology
people who tend to do the best in this
class who get an A make flashcards so
how you can do this you can either make
them yourself you can buy an index card
you can get on Microsoft Word create
columns and tables and just fold the
piece of paper together if you want to
be save money so you don't have to buy
index cards you can do this many
different ways or you can go and buy
flashcards there's companies like Kaplan
that make individual flashcards it comes
in like a box and you can review those
if you want to do that but I really
recommend that you actually create these
flashcards yourself and the reason why
is because whenever you're looking
through your book or you're looking
through your class notes and you're
having to create the flashcards yourself
you're actually having to write out the
side effects how it works on the body
its definitions and then you're having
to flip the card over and write the drug
name and things like that so not only
are you going to be reviewing that
flashcard but you're also learning by
having to actually process by your brain
and your hand you're having to write
everything out so that's another way of
learning to help you and another way is
to actually whenever you're creating
these you start creating these
flashcards after each lecture class
instead of creating them like the day or
two before the exam because as we
discussed the beginning of the video
pharmacology covers a lot of material
and you don't want to be stuck two days
before the exam creating flashcards
because that's not going to give you
enough time to actually study those
flashcards so I recommend after each
lecture class that you go home later
that day and you make flashcards based
on what your professor covered in the
course and what correlated in the
chapters and just make those flashcards
then go over each flashcard
we say them out loud repeat them through
rote memorization so you can remember
that because studies have shown that
what we learn and process in class that
if we don't review that the same day
that we're going to forget 70 to 80
percent of that material so you want to
do that to help you not do that
and it's a good idea that you carry
these flashcards that you make around
with you say you're waiting at a
doctor's office or you're just lounging
around the house or you have nothing
else to do or you're waiting outside of
a classroom for your other lecture class
to start you can just get out your
flashcards and just start reviewing them
because they're so easy to carry around
and that's just easy access time just
study and how people quiz you hand them
to your friend hand them to your
boyfriend's spouse and say hey go to
these flashcards with me in quiz me
that's another easy way that someone can
help actually quiz you and there's
actually a website called study STATCOM
that you can go to it has where it can
actually create flashcards for you if
you wanted that or they have a
pharmacology section where a lot of
people have uploaded flashcards that you
can access for free and use those but I
really recommend that creating
flashcards to help you study in
pharmacology is a great tool now let's
look at some other study strategies okay
next
another thing you want to do is you want
to get a drug guide this is like a
little pocket drug guide that has taken
all the major drugs that you're ever
going to have to know and put it in a
grey it's sort of like a dictionary
encyclopedia type deal but it's a
handheld that you can put in your pocket
and most professors will recommend what
type of drug guide you'll go should go
with so go by their recommendation and
this is just super handy because like I
said it's set up like a dictionary and
say you were making your flashcard for
digoxin and you're not familiar with
what it is so you look it up and you're
creating your flashcard it will right
there it'll have the side effects
nursing interventions the pharma Kinesis
and everything literally right there for
you you can write all that on your
flashcard flip it over right digoxin and
you're ready to go
instead of have
your lecture book which this stuff will
be scattered throughout you'll have this
section they'll be talking about side
effects then you'll have this section
they'll be talking about pharma Kinesis
and things like that you'll be spending
a lot of time going back and forth but
the drug guide will help to simplify
things for you so I really recommend you
invest in one of those next create fun
mnemonics and illustrations this is so
important especially whenever you're in
a section of drugs that maybe don't
share the same prefixes or suffixes
because some drugs don't have the same
prefixes or suffixes and you're in a
troubled area for instance I always had
trouble remembering how beta 1 and beta
2 drugs worked on the body and one time
I found this great illustration that
said and it was like a picture of a
heart and it said beta 1 for the heart
but one works on the heart and it's only
one organ then beta 2 it showed a
picture of two lungs so beta 2 works on
the lungs and just seeing that imagery
helped me remember it finally and also
if you're not good at creating them on a
Google and Pinterest are really great
because they have free resources for you
to use that other people have just so
graciously put on there for you to help
you remember so really recommend that
can help go a long way in remembering
too difficult things that maybe you're
just having trouble to understand next
teaching others this is so important
even though it sounds so simple and it's
like well how in the world would that
work but teaching others it really does
work because whenever you actually are
going to teach a friend or even say you
don't have anyone to teach is just
yourself
whenever you actually have to speak and
formulate sentences and talk your brain
is processing that and understanding
that and it's just sinking in more than
if you were just looking at it reading
it silently because your brain is
processing that you're actually having
to verbalize that with your vocal cord
and your brain is having to figure out
the correct words you want to use so
teaching others really helps and like I
said if you don't have someone to teach
just review side-effects and say those
side effects
over and over and explain how it works
on the body and what drug groups are
part of that it's a really good way to
help understand this material and next
you'll want to get a study guide this
really goes a long way there's a lot of
study guides out there so you want to
pick the best one you can i really
recommend whenever you're looking at
study guides you can go to amazon.com
and look at the reviews see what other
students are saying but what study
guides do is that they help break down
the material in your chapters into
easier terms without all the fancy lingo
and things like that and a lot of these
study guides will have great mnemonics
in them great illustrations great little
study aids to help you memorize this
material because they know it's hard and
they know that other people have had
trouble with it and a lot of them will
come with test questions that you may
see that are similar on your exam that
your professor gives you one just off
the top of my head that I recommend
it's called made easy pharmacology it's
a great little study guide to help
compliment your book and sometimes some
lecture books have a study guide to go
along with that but that's just an extra
little thing that will condense the
material down help you whenever you're
making flashcards and just point out to
you the most important material to study
and I want it in with this do not give
up pharmacology is a tough course has a
lot of material in it and it has a lot
of things that you have to memorize so
if you didn't do good on the first test
or maybe you're struggling right now you
have no idea what to do don't give up
take those study strategies that I gave
you pick one pick two make them your own
and try the hardest a lot of people have
trouble with this class but you can do
it and you can ace it and thank you so
much for watching this video and please
check out our other teaching tutorials
and our other videos on how to study for
other classes in nursing school and
thank you so much for watching and
please subscribe to this YouTube channel